i was like living in my moth's basement
at the time i was like 15 worked at a
pet shop and were you doing drugs or
anything at the time oh yeah yeah yeah
that i don't do drugs now i don't do
drugs now but yeah but it wasn't because
of snakes it was just because i was a
rock guy right right yeah yeah whatever
i'm just trying to get the whole picture
i don't know if it's a guy like a kind
of a nerdy kid down you know i don't
know if it's a science kid down there
doing volcanoes doing snakes or if it's
a kid like uh you know what i'm saying
is listening to some mega death and some
ac dc negative a little bit of gas and
then petting something you know yeah
well you know i was always pretty good
about not messing with the snakes when i
was uh you know partying it up a little
bit should somebody that's high because
first of all two two questions one
i think i i remember
my friend alex had a snake he would feed
it we he would feed his snake dog food
pieces is that possible or was i
you probably hi you're probably high
okay i mean i'm not gonna say that it
can't happen i'm just saying that i've
never seen it okay yeah because i was
i've had this memory my whole life and
then i'm like i don't know if maybe
we're high so then the second part is do
you think drug induced people should be
around snakes and what
sorry answer
no
no one talk listen you know any animal
especially a a reptile or a big cat or
you know something that could
potentially hurt you and yeah listen a
lot of snakes can't hurt you but i'm
talking a bigger snake you know we have
a rule that like number one you can't
even go in with a big animal without a
second person with you in our place but
uh and no one can be intoxicated on any
level okay
say you have to be intoxicated right
there's a federal mandate you know and
i'm not talking like with the vaccine
i'm talking like federally mandated you
gotta be you gotta be high some type of
drug yeah what is this best drug to be
on around a snake probably marijuana you
know because children you know maybe
they've sensed a little energy thing or
something like that i know a lot of
keepers that smoke a lot of reefer yeah
yeah i yeah i feel like that fits now
what is a drug that would you would not
recommend probably being on around
definitely not like mushrooms or lsd
yeah that'd be a bad idea really yeah i
mean you're barely knowing what's going
on you got some snakes striking at you
you know you think it's maybe a goblin
or something like that is a snake more
likely to strike at you if you have uh
sunglasses on
uh
probably not
some animals would i would say like
lizards like giant lizards and stuff
like that they get a little freaked out
by stuff like that they're more visual
you know what i mean snakes aren't as
visual what about skin lotion like a
vino skin lotion like a basic
moisturizer uh probably nothing too
major to be honest with you i've never
seen anything too agitated by smells and
stuff like that
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two
options watch one this one or this one